[Music]
what happened before the big bang
does it even make sense to speculate
about the universe before
the origin of matter
time and space of our own universe
these are the questions tackled in an
infinity of worlds by my friend will
kinney who's a professor at the state
university of new york at buffalo
it's been
widely praised both by advanced readers
and blurbers such as myself and another
brian brian green
you'll find our comments alongside of
those of sabine hassenfelder and others
like stefan alexander all guests on the
show in the past
this book takes us on a journey into the
essence of time and the most
controversial theory of them all
the multiverse
is it possible that there are an
infinity of other universes not just
worlds not just planets not just stars
galaxies
but of other universes
can we ever hope to find experimental
evidence or a refutation of such a claim
why is it so controversial what does he
make of so-called multiverse deniers we
talked about all that and we also got in
to the patented thrilling three
questions of existential reality
that you'll subscribe to my newsletter
at primekeeping.com to get
for now come join me as we go into the
impossible asking the question of the
nature of time and space itself before
our universe even existed come along
let's go into the impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
well it's a pleasure to welcome today
another friend and author of a brand new
book popular science
called an infinity of worlds and it's a
magical book uh that really takes us on
a tour
as uh this book was blurbed by two
brians two eminent brians one my kids
favorite brian in all of cosmology and
that's brian greene uh he blurbed it but
then another brian o'brien keating
blurbed it saying it thoroughly
documents the latest observations and
challenges to the theory of cosmological
inflation will kidneys shimmering prose
demystifies the most inscrutable cosmic
epoch eliminating the way forward for
future generations
to explore its manifold mysteries
so uh that is what i thought about it
and uh the author is here today
professor will kinney of the state
university of nuevo york where i used to
hang out getting some wick some roast
beef on wick no doubt it's will kinney
how are you will
good brian thanks appreciate the blurb
by the way
the other brian of course you may know
is uh is my old boss actually i was a
postdoc for him at columbia for three
years
so uh he's an old friend
and there are other
incomia on the back of the book
including uh by our friend sabina
hassenfelder
who had much kinder things to say about
your book than my book it should be
noted uh only antagonistic blur by no no
she didn't write a blur and then by our
friend professor stefan alexander
as well who is professor at brown
university where i was a graduate
student lo these many years ago
and i want to start will as long time
listeners to the show viewers of the
show now we start
with a special segment when someone is a
guest who has written a book and then we
end with a special segment that we call
the thrilling three existential
questions but now we're going to start
with our patented
segment that we call judging books by
their covers
[Music]
so will we're going to do what you're
advised never to do which is to judge a
book by its cover and i want to ask you
um how did you come up with the title
the cover design the subtitle tell me
how you did so for this wonderful new
work of science popularization
so this is the cover and the title so
the the title is the main title is an
infinity of worlds and the subtitle is
cosmic inflation in the beginning of the
universe uh the subtitle should be
fairly self-explanatory that's the
scientific subject of the book
um the the main title is actually uh a
quote
from the
sort of uh
the
guy who is a in many ways the
philosophical heart of the book which is
the renaissance astronomer giordano
bruno
um who was a
copernican philosopher in the late 1500s
who
in a way really he took copernicus's
idea of uh this is this concept that
copernicus came up with the that the
earth is special right if you're going
to have a heliocentric cosmology you're
going to have the earth move just be one
of the planets you kind of have to
demote it
from
its
its special place in the universe
and
bruno took
copernicus's ideas and extended them
further than copernicus ever dared to
uh and he uh borrowed a lot of ideas
from uh earlier philosophers the
epicureans who um believed in
an infinity of worlds uh and so the the
the title is a quote from giordano bruno
and bruno wrote in 1584 in a book called
on the infinite universe and worlds
quote god is infinite so his universe
must be two he is glorified not in one
but in countless sons not in a single
earth a single world but in a thousand
thousand i say in an infinity of worlds
and so the title is a reference to
giordano bruno's 1584 work on the
infinity of worlds it's worth noting
that bruno's belief in an infinity of
rules was
one of eight charges of heresy that were
leveled against him
which ultimately
resulted in him being burned at the
stake at campo de fiore in 1600
uh another one being uh his uh uh
advocacy for a heliocentric cosmology as
well
so
so the the title is a direct reference
to my man giordano bruno who uh was in
my opinion really hundreds of years
ahead of his time
yeah so
you're actually the second guest on the
into the impossible podcast to compare
himself to giordano bruno the first
being avi loeb um we'll get into that
i'm not comparing myself to bruno i'm
just teasing by him
i'm just teasing i always say when you
get a referee report back the thing that
you should never do is compare yourself
to the plight of giordano bruno oh i
kind of heard was kind of a little bit
of a schmuck in some ways in that he he
had actually you know uh
known very full well what he was doing
and kind of extended similar to what
galileo did right galileo was forbidden
to teach copernicism but he could
research it that's why he wasn't
convicted of heresy or killed or you
know really tortured beyond you know
bending down and kissing the pope's ring
or whatever he had to do to recant but
uh nevertheless can you i mean this this
book is not mainly about that but
that the topic of of worlds in his
conception was really that the stars
were were sort of like other sons but
was it really that each one had a planet
and on each planet there were people and
then the problem was jesus couldn't
visit all these and this is a jew
talking to i don't know what you are but
uh but
actually but yeah
i used to be i used to be a a a catholic
uh altar boy but well those days are
long behind me
oh yeah so what was the heresy
yeah so one of the things was
bruno was an extraordinarily abrasive
personality uh by all reports and uh
managed to piss off just about everybody
so he was actually
turned in to the inquisition by a friend
who was visiting he was visiting right
so he was hanging out at a friend's
house and the friend uh tipped off the
inquisition who uh apparently he was a
pretty poor houseguest uh is the only
thing i can think of there but and he
was imprisoned for seven years before he
was executed and unlike galileo didn't
even make any pretense of recanting i
mean he was very stubborn and uh
eventually it resulted in his death
um
but bruno's
yeah bruno thought of the other stars as
correctly as being other sons which
would have planets around them which
would have other civilizations like ours
he was as far as i know i spent a lot of
time reading him when i was writing this
book i didn't read any other like pop
science or anything but i read a lot of
bruno while i was writing the book
and his concern primarily was
um
the problem of in the uh uh
atomic cosmology right that so that
there was a whole theology built
around the talmah cosmology in which
heaven was a place right it was outside
the crystal sphere uh uh about the outer
sphere of the universe right so the in
the ptolemaic universe the earth is at
the center and there are various spheres
going outward the crystal sphere of the
stars and then the prima mobile which
was a sphere outside the sphere of the
stars and finally the imperium realm
which was outside the premium mobile
and if you get rid of that structure you
have nowhere left for god to live
and so now so bruno says okay there's a
we have a copernican universe it's
infinite and extent there are an
infinity of worlds just like our own
here then does god reside
uh and his solution to this problem was
once again borrowing from the epicureans
he uh
he believed that god actually lived
inside atoms
uh and so it was this uh sort of god was
uh eminent from the smallest structures
in the universe so it was a it was kind
of a form of pantheism almost where
where god was resonant in the smallest
particles of the universe uh rather than
living in some place that was outside
the universe uh was his solution to this
problem so his cosmology was very very
prescient it was very far ahead of its
time his theology was like completely
nuts
uh and you know so he had god living
inside the atoms that corresponded and
it was that he came up with all these
crazy theories that of course have not
really survived the test of time
although you know past guests on the
show michio kaku will call you know the
equations of string theory the god
equation so if not uh in in literal form
you know we have vestiges of bruno and
those uh pantheistic ideas
um and i wonder you know when we when we
think about communicating uh to the
public and you've done a spectacular job
in this brand new book the
uh infinity of of worlds um
when you take on a writing a book what
um you know
to be blunt you know what made you want
to undertake this you're a professor
you're doing hardcore research advising
students
what made it uh you know incumbent upon
you
to take on this mission to describe uh
the multiverse from this perspective
why was that such a priority for you at
this stage in your career
uh well the the story of how this
happened is that mit press actually came
to me and said hey we're looking for
somebody to write a book on inflation uh
and we think you'd be a good person to
do it and so
uh i said sure uh and so they they it i
probably wouldn't have written it if
they hadn't uh hadn't recruited me to do
it i i didn't have any particular
ambition in mind to write a pop science
book
it's a difficult task
um but once it got going it was uh and
to be honest i didn't really have like
you know when i started working on it
it's like okay so you're doing an
explainer on inflation it's sort of what
they asked me for was a 40 000 word
explainer on inflation and what they got
was a 47 000 word manifesto on
copernicanism and and uh my editor
jeremy matthews was was very uh kind
about that uh in terms of he sort of got
what he asked for but he got a lot more
than he asked for in a lot of ways and
uh
so but
uh but he recognized that you know he
saw the potential in it and uh
so we decided to put it out as a
hardback trade book
um so
but it became increasingly evident as
you start writing this is that you can't
write about inflation without writing
about eternal inflation in the
multiverse
and that gets you into sticky
philosophical territory extremely
quickly
and so i found that structuring it
around
uh
bruno's ideas gave me a gave me a place
to situate it and in particular sort of
a reaction against the popularity of
anthropic principle in cosmology uh
which i spend rather
i criticize at length in the book
and one of the themes of the book is
proposing a copernican viewpoint on the
multiverse that is an alternative to
this anthropic viewpoint
and really when the anthropic principle
this is the idea that
uh to explain this to your listeners who
might not be familiar with it is the
idea that
the universe appears to be fine-tuned
for life the strength of
electromagnetism is just so the the
structure of atoms is just so the the
universe is uh uh seems to be built to
form galaxies and planets and things
like that it's almost like it's built
for us to live in it
uh and this has been remarked upon by a
number of authors
um
and so
my viewpoint is a bit of a reaction to
that so the the idea of the anthropic
principle is that the laws of physics
are what they are in order to enable our
existence in some sense in the weakest
form it's just saying that we wouldn't
be here if the laws of physics were
different so that we can say that you
know the laws of physics have to be
consistent with our existence that's a
basic consistency condition
but i think in stronger form where it's
as if that you can use that as a
predictive tool to actually decide to
predict what the value for example the
the density of dark energy or the value
the strength of electromagnetism that's
where it gets more uh
controversial
and
that this picture is that in this in a
great multiverse if you have many many
many universes almost all of them the
vast overwhelming majority i mean
mathematically hugely will be these
empty barren places that have no life in
them at all and we live in this very
special oasis that is built just for us
the alternative viewpoint is that
our universe is in some sense typical
it's extending this copernican idea that
the earth is typical or the solar system
is typical in the universe out to the
idea that our universe is very likely
typical in this larger multiverse
uh and so it's the a lot of the
philosophical treatment of the book is
is the
contrast and the clash between these two
viewpoints on how one would structure a
larger universe of which ours is only
apart
so
looking you know from the present
backwards is how i typically will think
about teaching cosmology as i'm doing
right now with my students some of whom
are undoubtedly watching right now
because their entire grade depends on
their subscription to my youtube channel
i'm just kidding that's not true but um
but many of them do follow the channel
and uh are taking in a class based on
past guest barbara ryden's wonderful
introduction to cosmology textbook it's
a great book it is it's one of my
favorite books that i pointed out to the
students i think it's the
most widely read uh of all books because
it's it's the primary book for cosmology
in general and to my knowledge i confirm
this is barbara i think it's the most
widely read textbook
for undergrads written by uh a female
professor which is pretty amazing when
you think about how 99 of the books are
not uh and so it's remarkable and that
she's such a delightful intellect and
playful person and and just genius
and writing but in that book we don't we
end with inflation but really i always
felt that was kind of like putting the
cart before the horse i mean shouldn't
we start by talking about the beginning
of the universe and teach the
controversy uh so to speak and and that
um you know learning about the evolution
of the universe has some bearing we have
to say something about cosmogenesis but
i but by the time i get to inflation at
the end of the quarter
there's usually you know no time left to
really dwell into it but really it's
kind of the reason a lot of them are
taking the clause right so so what what
does inflation have to say about
cosmogenesis cosmogeny the origin of the
universe itself
if anything or is it just assuming that
the universe began to exist and if so
what what quandaries does that pose for
physicists such as yourself
a lot of complicated questions certainly
i mean the the
the selling point of inflation is
its reason to be there is that inflation
is a dynamical way to set the boundary
conditions for the hot big bang
this gets a little funny because the
word big bang is you is a loaded word
that's used in many ways so big bang
refers to in one sense it refers to this
hot dense early stage of the universe
which we know was there yeah because of
things like the cosmic microwave
background and primordial abundances of
the elements we know that the universe
was hot it was in thermal equilibrium it
was dominated by relativistic species
but there's also the big bang sometimes
also refers to the initial singularity
right if you take the standard
cosmological model you run it backward
in time you find that the universe has a
finite age
and at that
time as time zero there was a there was
a point at which the universe became so
dense that all the known laws of physics
break down in some sense and this is the
initial singularity
inflation replaces that initial
singularity with
a an earlier epoch and the end of
inflation is the end of that earlier
epoch and the onset of this hot thermal
equilibrium universe
so that thermal equilibrium the hot
dense early universe of the big bang
is a consequence of inflation so
inflation explains why the universe is
so big
why it is so close to geometrically flat
which is an observed fact that is not
explained by the standard cosmological
model uh
and uh so
and so why it's geometrically flat light
so old why it's so big
um inflation the the other question is
does inflation get rid of that initial
singularity right so
the end of inflation is now where the
initial singularity was in the standard
big bang model
um
but you can now ask the question does
inflation
get rid of the initial singularity or
does it just displace it to some earlier
time
and there are theorems on this
that show that in fact that initial
singularity doesn't disappear but it
just gets pushed far far back into a
murky past of what happened before
inflation itself
and inflation doesn't provide any real
answers to that question
uh so unfortunately it doesn't allow us
to get rid of the initial singularity
that led to the big bang all it does is
separate that from that initial hot
hot dense equilibrium state uh that was
the early universe as we as we can
observe it i mean one of the consistent
themes on this channel and i'll put
links to videos i've had conversations
with people like uh paul steinhardt
giant narlikar and uh and even sir roger
penrose
all of whom have alternative cosmologies
to inflation and one of the
um selling points of this book that i
found refreshing is that it doesn't you
know assume
that uh that inflation had to be
occurring and that it's the only choice
it's the only thing that you could
possibly consider but if i got the gist
of it right uh and it's going back about
six months since i read it uh but uh but
but the fact that if inflation did occur
then it's sort of unavoidable that there
was something like a singularity right
that that you basically can avoid this
according to the so-called border guth
blanken uh theorem um and yet one one
issue i have with that and i've raised
with roger penrose as well is that you
know we have no examples of
singularities in physics as far as i
understand it mathematics they're
abundant they're resplendent but
what evidence do we have for anything
being infinite in in temperature
pressure density however whatever
physical unit you want to use that's
infinite and then furthermore
transitioning from something infinite to
something uh finite and some finite
amount of time so the concept of
singularities often gets brought up in
the context of of quantum gravity that
we need a theory of quantum gravity
because we need to understand a
the origin of the universe
because that seemed to require a
singularity
and
or to understand the properties of
singularities in black holes
but will neither one of these is in
principle even observable
so so to what extent do we need to have
a singularity at all as mandated by the
fact we can never observe it uh and
therefore does the bgv theorem fall
apart because there's no evidence that
there could be a singularity in other
words
this is kind of the house of cards
argument
yeah i mean the bgb theorem which says
there must be a singularity in
inflationary space times an initial one
is a as a classical theorem it doesn't
include quantum mechanics right so the
supposition here is that when you
have a theory of quantum gravity
that it will resolve those singularities
in some way that it will it will take
these points of infinity and turn them
into something and and chop them off in
some way
resolve them so that they're not
actually infinite
some application of the heisenberg
uncertainty principle the space time
that would mean that that singularity
really never goes to infinity so things
don't don't fall into an infinite point
at the center of a black hole and the
universe doesn't evolve out of a
singular uh out of a space-time signal
sorry sorry to interrupt but if there
was if there was this heisenberg kind of
classical you know quasi-classical wkb
transition i mean doesn't that then
obviate the bgv theorem and that like
now you're saying you've smoothed out
the singularity so then you can't
extrapolate that there was an eternal
inflation going forward because there
wasn't an initial singularity to begin
with it was a classical high density you
know caustic or something
uh
you don't know i mean there's no theory
for it right so nobody's constructed a
theory of quantum theory of
singularities and because we don't have
a theory of quantum gravity we don't
have a self-consistent theory of how you
resolve singularities people assume that
it will be true once we have a theory of
quantum gravity but we don't know that
right it could well be that when we come
up with a theory of quantum gravity it
will still contain singularities we
don't know uh
so that's the alternate possibility
um but the the thing that's fortunate is
those are all hidden behind horizons
and so because of the presence of
space-time horizons which are boundaries
beyond which you can't see for example
the event horizon of a black hole or
correspondingly in cosmology the the
edge of our observable universe because
those singularities are hidden behind
those horizons we never have
observational access to them it's to a
certain extent it's
you start to ask the question is this
really science at all right instead of
this blurry boundary between a proper
scientific proposition and a purely
philosophical one
would be my viewpoint on that
and then you know considering these um
you know the delightful description that
you have of some of the competitor
theories
if i asked you to put on your montana by
the way you're my at least third guest
from montana if i if i have that right
um sarah rugheimer
uh professor rugheimer uh and then uh
brian schmidt another one of my kids
favorite brian's um so uh at least third
and there may be more montana what is it
about montana that creates is it the big
sky that you then want to pursue the
biggest questions under the sky
i i got no answer for you there
um
cannons are a peculiar bunch yes that's
right mavericks all of you um uh it is
probably a high a very high ratio of uh
astronomers per capita or professors of
physics or astronomy per capita um when
we think about the alternatives that you
very um you know delightfully do discuss
in this book which you know well i get i
get a little bit frustrated i've
reviewed a book i forget who the author
was now but for physics today about
three or four years ago it was also
about the multiverse and in it uh the
guy the author and again i'm not going
to use his name but he calls like people
that that don't support the multiverse
multiverse deniers
um that's his literal term and uh and i
railed against that in my review for
physics today but nevertheless i mean
how do you look at people and is it is
it like global warming or god forbid
holocaust denial i hate these you know
kind of comparisons but he brought it up
so i want to ask you if you if you
question inflation does that make you a
crank i mean how how do you address
these people that are deniers or or
supporters of alternative cosmogenic um
you know instantiations before the hot
big bank
well they're legitimate theories and you
know one of the things is that inflation
the inflation has definite shortcomings
and i discuss these you know in in
detail in the book so one of them is
this problem of that the bgb theorem it
doesn't get rid of the initial
singularity so you really haven't solved
the problem of the universe coming into
being out of nothing
which physicists don't like right
because we like to have a continuous
chain of cause and effect and that and
you if the universe had a beginning it
had to have a first cause as i got an
idea of going all the way back to
aristotle so people have tried to come
up with alternatives that solve this
problem that really push the you know
give you a universe that can extend
infinitely into the past and infinitely
into the future
which i think is a bias that most
physicists have about the world that uh
we really don't like the idea of the
universe having had a beginning it makes
physicists uncomfortable
um
so i and i and these
one of the other usefulnesses of an
alternative theory that i want to bring
up is that
it allows you to say okay i have a
theory that has certain shortcomings
um
what are the alternatives in the sense
of what hap what price do i have to pay
in order to
compensate for those shortcomings of
this other theory i mean is is my
alternative
does it have even more shortcomings or
is it
is it better and i think i argue in the
book that these alternatives although
they're self-consistent and certainly
possible right you can't really
there's there's no
observational way necessarily to rule
them out
although for example in the case of
steinhardt's cyclic models
you would rule them out by detecting
primordial gravitational waves since
they're not produced in that so there's
a real definite prediction there you can
say if we find
primordial gravitational waves from the
big bang then uh these these cyclic
models that steinhardt has proposed
would be
falsified
so you look at these alternatives even
if you feel like inflation is the
preferred model and i certainly do
the alternatives give you considering
alternatives gives you a
a sense of
uh what the boundaries of your existing
theories are and how how you might
how you might
work around the existing shortcomings of
the theory and i and what i argue in the
book is that these alternatives
introduce more problems than they solve
really they have different problems but
they're in many ways worse
um
and then yet you know just a pushback
with respect as i always do you know and
speaking not on behalf of paul
steinhardt or anna he just
upcoming guest on the podcast um you
know they will say that their model in
particular with you know doesn't require
a singularity so it has a classical
bounce
and um and also accounts for entropic
considerations which inflation also has
to explain as pointed out by none other
than sir roger penrose what i like about
the alternatives and i'll have to you
know not dwell too long on this but
they're the three major alternatives you
know the narlikar quasi-steady
quasi-steady-state cosmology with the
sea field that kind of eventually kind
of looked like
dark energy according to them ruled out
by cmb polarization in particular as i
discussed in my book but um and then
paul's book uh paul's work rather with
anna aegis
and uh even sir roger penrose not only
do they kind of criticize inflation they
can they can attack but they also
promote new alternative ideas that's
kind of rare in in in science in other
words it's easy to attack there are a
lot of people that say dark energy
doesn't exist you know dark matter
doesn't exist but they don't come up
with some other alternatives to explain
existing data they just show current
data is inconsistent with the precepts
of the theory and yet anna paul
roger even giant
they propose alternative models which
are testable as you just said they can
be falsified
and i think you know is that is that not
right to require as a virtue as paul has
said as you undoubtedly know from the
scientific american you know back and
forth which is reminiscent of the
index of paul gave many talks on this as
well yeah
so
you know thinking about the the the
notion of uh of testability in the
scientific method he's claimed not only
is inflation wrong it's dangerous it's
dangerous not only to science but to
society because it up ends our kind of
cherished notions about uh
predictability and testability and and
kind of the popparian sense so how do
you react to that that that inflation i
think that's complete bunk and i think
he is totally wrong about it
well inflation makes a whole bunch of
really definite predictions especially
if you look at uh you know
consider
the simplest type of inflation model
which just has a single order parameter
right a single dynamical degree of
freedom that makes a whole laundry list
of very very definite predictions it
predicts that
the perturbations should be purely
adiabatic that is that they should uh
they should uh
couple directly to the curvature it
predicts that the perturbation should be
nearly scale invariant but not quite
uh it says that the perturbation should
be a gaussian random field and it
predicts the existence of primordial
gravitational waves three of those four
things have been tested in detail by
observations and all of them turned out
to be right
so this idea that inflation can predict
anything
well
in a sense that's true it's in the sense
in the same sense that quantum field
theory can predict anything you know any
observation you can come up with a field
theory that will fit it
but the standard model is extremely
predictive as a quantum field theory and
i think the situation is the same as
inflation so the the the larger picture
of using you know quantum field theory
to describe a
a a
accelerating expansion in the early
universe is very broad
but uh model builders and and
inflationary models particular models of
inflation make extremely precise uh
predictions and those predictions have
been borne out by data
so it it's it's it seems to me that
saying that inflation doesn't predict
anything it keeps raising the bar so you
know
other than all of these other things
that it predicted and came true well
what has it done for us lately and i i
think it's a little bit of a
disingenuous argument and i i just don't
buy it uh well yeah i mean just to dwell
on it and i'm not asking you to you know
i'm not speaking on behalf of paul or
anna uh necessarily but of course
they'll bring up as did sir roger
penrose issues of you know consistency
the extraordinarily low entropy required
in the uh inflationary paradigm at very
early times um obviously the singularity
unresolved singularity issue
and oftentimes when i hear this people
say well
first of all the multiverse isn't a
theory it's a consequence of inflation
and then they'll say inflation's not a
theory they'll say inflation's sort of a
paradigm and i've argued with paul even
respectfully saying look it would be
great if you didn't need a quantum field
you know but yeah and and sir roger has
a quantum field in other words if you're
gonna sub you know subvert inflation
you would be great if you did it without
some magical scalar field that somehow
is present you know perhaps all time
internally going forward um
but uh but nevertheless he has a quantum
field and a scalar field at that of
which we only know there's one example
right the higgs the only known scalar
field right so uh the fact that all
these alternatives need scalar fields
the sea field and in narlikar and hoyle
uh the scalar field of ann aegis and
paul steinhardt
and then sir roger penrose has these
error bonds and and so forth uh none of
which
can we observe involved with scalar
fields as you know yeah what's that yeah
i'm saying all these do so i'm saying to
get rid of it to have an alternative to
inflation be nice not to have the core
element of inflation which is a scalar
which as you know paul was very
instrumental in understanding in early
times in the 1980s rather
early times
to the model of anna and paul that that
involves a scalar field and also
involves inflation it involves
accelerating expansion that's how they
get rid of the entropy that builds up
right but it doesn't involve that what
they call the quantum runaway and the
multiverse right there is no multiverse
there are no b modes you know i'd be out
of a job you know so you know obviously
i'm pulling for it but i mean just
thinking back you know historically uh
going back to say uh the early
discoveries of the cmb
um before the cmb was was discovered in
65 the there were many predictions by
people like uh like um gamov and others
um working together and they kept
fluctuating some days the the cmb
temperature would be five kelvin other
days would be 20 kelvin and there were
some early measurements in cyanogen and
other things by mckellar uh but yet we
you know the fact that the numbers kept
fluctuating and as hoyle said when the
cmb was discovered you know if they had
measured you know 2.9 kelvin or 6.9
kelvin they would have said that's
consistent with the with the big bang of
course you depending on what your
starting temperature is that's true i
mean it's just a consequence of
radiation domination right so to what
extent i i remember and i may be wrong
but i want to give you credit i remember
as a grad student you know making these
plots of you know tensor to scalar ratio
versus n sub s i believe you were the
first person to to make those types of
plots we invented that right so that was
me and scott dodelson and rocky cole
were the people who invented the zoo
plot that's zoopla yeah so now the zoo
plot of course there's not only you know
an infinite number of points that can
tile a plane uh there's an infinite
seeming infinite number my former
post-doc i met yadav you know once wrote
a paper already listed every single name
of every model of employee so there is
no one theory of inflation right and and
even the classification of inflation um
single field just seems natural but
there's no letter from god or you know
gaia whoever that says it has to be
single field so do you think of
inflation as a theory like bbn or how do
you think about it like when you wake up
and work on it
back to the predictivity issue right so
if you take that uh that that plot of n
sub s versus tensor tensor fraction uh
you can
pick any region of that and you can find
an inflation model that will land there
right inflation different choices of
inflationary potential densely tile that
plane yeah which you know back a long
time ago that was not really well
established one of the questions i
remember was rocky who first asked you
know it's like do do inflation models
fill this densely or do they live in
particular regions and uh it took a
while to answer that question and it
turns out they fill it densely that
there's no particular prediction
but that's not any different than saying
you know newton's law of gravity tells
or kepler's laws tells you to tell you
how planets orbit but it doesn't tell
you the radius of the planetary orbits
kepler had another theory involving
platonic solids that he claimed
predicted predicted the orbits of the
planetary radiation but he didn't have
one over r cubed one of our r to the
fourth you know he had none
or multiple gravitational fields like
multiple scalar fields
so you know yeah there is that degree of
freedom and we really don't know and
then so you have this free function that
you can use to fit uh this data but in
the case of a single field model it will
still always be gaussian and it will
still always be adiabatic all of these
other things will be true it's just that
it doesn't make any particular
prediction for example for the amplitude
of the tensor modes it predicts they'll
be there but there's no prediction of
how strong they will be so they it might
be that you will never see the b mode
right
because the the tensor fraction is just
too small
so i i don't consider that necessarily a
crushing lack of predictivity for the
inflationary paradigm
we know for example that
uh alternative theories involving
uh
what are called non-canonical
lagrangians things that are very common
in string theory predict that you would
have uh a speed of sound during
inflation that's much much less than the
speed of light and those can be ruled
out we have a lower bound on what the
speed of sound was and inflation of
about eight percent of the speed of
light it has to be bigger than that
uh but from measurements of
non-gaussianity
so there are lots of
there's lots of theories that have
already been falsified
uh and it turns out that the very
simplest theory is these single field
models are still perfectly consistent
with the data so whatever you want might
want to criticize them on the basis of
it's like no there is no
there's no writ from god that tells us
it has to be that this way but what we
know about things like phase transitions
and other kinds of symmetry breaking in
nature is that uh these single order
parameter phase transitions are very
common and there's no reason to a
particular reason to expect that it
wouldn't have been that way and it
certainly fits the data so we have a
model that works extremely well
uh and i consider that a real triumph
with respect to the singular i wanted to
bring up that uh in for example in the
uh paul and anna's latest uh uh cyclic
universe right
which
definitely avoids a singularity at the
bounce right so they have a contracting
universe that then goes through a bounce
and then expands again and they have a
modified gravity theory that explains
the bounds you have to modify general
relativity to get rid of that
singularity so that they add that in
um but one of the questions that we had
was
does that really avoid the initial
singularity right so inflation you have
the bgv theorem that tells you that the
singularity still has to be there in the
past
and at first glance the cyclic models
where the universe just is cyclic in
time
seem to avoid that problem that there's
no initial singularity
and this came out after i finished the
book but i actually still i had had this
uh derivation in mind when i was writing
the book is that we
my grad student nina stein and i
recently came out with a paper
where we show that the bgv theorem that
tells you that there's an initial
singularity in inflation also applies to
the steinhardt ios model
right their model also has an initial
singularity of exactly the same time
that inflation does so in fact their
model does not avoid that problem it's
they have right which to be fair they
so as i understand it and
about 10 years ago
with bars and turok you know paul
discovered that that also applied or
they did apply it to cyclic cosmology so
um
you know that was that was sort of uh
you know dependent contingent perhaps on
some new higgs field type behavior but
um
but yeah so so i think just to recap for
listeners is getting a little bit into
the weeds and of course
technically yeah but uh but it's fun
because my audience is extremely
technically uh savvy and i i reserve the
right to always uh
to go as deep as my guests will be
willing to go but i think it's it's
important to hear you know for the for
even a lay person that that these are
topics worthy of debate that we should
debate with with committee and some
comedy too uh that the you know that
there are alternatives and that they're
worth exploring and not necessarily as
previous people saying didn't call it
deniers or so forth um that i find kind
of a little bit disappointing that's
extremely unhelpful yeah i mean yeah uh
now talk about some of the consequences
i mentioned the higgs inflation that
that um
steinhardt turok and bars had discussed
a little while back but um talk about
the higgs it could it be the higgs the
only scalar field we know
exists
and the inflaton
and maybe dark energy could they all be
related in some way
possible people have come up with models
for that as far as i know in order to
make the higgs work as the inflaton
which for your listeners is that
whatever field is responsible for
inflation we just give it a generic name
called the phleton like uh
like the higgs boson it's the particle
responsible for inflation yeah um it
could indeed be the higgs boson but
you pay a price to do that which is that
you have to have it coupled directly to
gravity in a very non-standard way
so that if you have what's called a
minimal model where you have the higgs
boson and gravity beings being separate
sectors of the theory the higgs boson
doesn't work because the potential is
too steep
it
rolls off the top of the hill too
quickly to be the inflaton but if you
couple it directly to gravity in a
non-standard way then you can make it
work for inflation and there's a number
of really interesting papers that have
been written on the subject about using
the higgs itself
so
possibly yeah
if uh some intelligent you know alien
wakes you up at three in the morning and
forces you to disclose your greatest
reason for credulity in inflation what
would it be
i
for me it uh um
i really started to view inflation as
being a well-established theory rather
than just a you know one of a number of
competing hypotheses
with the release of the wmap satellite
data
right so the first really uh high
high resolution high high sensitivity
all sky map of the cosmic microwave
background
that really fell exactly into where you
expected inflation to be and and that's
certainly been strengthened by
subsequent measurements like the plot
measurement and
the the things that you're involved with
like the bicep keck measurement at the
south pole
all of that evidence put together really
points to
confirming a set of predictions that
were made by inflationary cosmology long
long before the data came in and i think
that's a very powerful thing if you were
really uh making these and these aren't
trivial predictions they're complicated
calculations you're not just pulling
this out of a hat these are really
strong consequences of the theory and
the fact that the data matches so well
give me a lot more confidence that
inflation is right
um i've been a lot more dubious about
the multiverse for a long time and i was
harder to convince about that
but i've also finally come around on
that score as well
so what was the most convincing i mean
obviously you know most convincing of
all perhaps at least that's what we put
in our grant proposals would be a
detection of b mode polarization right
um you're smoking but there's there's an
additional smoking gun that we have seen
which is the presence of super horizon
perturbations
so
for the
for the listeners the observable
universe is a big as a little patch of a
much larger space
and
a prediction of inflation that you don't
get from really from
any other theory
is that you should have waves density
waves in the universe waves in the over
density and under density of the
universe whose wavelength is actually
larger than the size of the observable
universe where one end of the way this
wave is causally disconnected from the
other end of the wave
that is a really peculiar prediction of
inflationary cosmology that uh you don't
get in most other theories and it turns
out that there's very few theories that
will that will accommodate that
and there is very definite evidence in
the cosmic microwave background for the
presence of these super horizon
perturbations they're just there
and this is the really the biggest thing
that i think gives one confidence in
inflation is the correct theory is the
presence of these these modes with
wavelengths longer than the size of the
observable universe
that's extremely weird and doesn't come
about uh with
much physics that are that is
alternative to inflation
so a bouncing universe is being an
exception
so yeah bounce i was gonna mention that
and also just to be you know to push
back
on myself or maybe on paul
and anna uh is to say well you know
inflation could have been it's not true
to say that it can't be falsified if uh
because we could have measured that the
universe isn't flat like imagine we we
do much more precise you know angular
correlations or we you know get a
bearing acousticos yeah we do whatever
we need to do and within the context of
well that's a model dependency the
universe isn't flat um then would you
rule out i mean would that cause you
which is still an open possibility no
pun intended uh but would that then
cause you to doubt both the inflationary
paradigm and then per force the
multiverse you know kind of consequence
within inflation for example yeah we had
if the universe had turned out to have a
like a measurable positive curvature if
we lived in a closed universe i think
that that would be a very uh
very difficult to accommodate within
inflation you could probably come up
with some highly contrived model to do
it but it would be lots and lots of
gears and bells and whistles in order to
accomplish it right so
it would be unattractive
um another thing that i think would uh
have really made one uh question
inflation is if there hadn't been if
there weren't any acoustic peaks in the
cmb right we see these the evidence of
these coherent sound waves in the early
universe propagating in the plasma when
the cosmic microwave background formed
that for example would not be there if
structure were seeded by cosmic strings
instead of by adiabatic perturbations
right cosmic strings would have given
you just a big featureless bump in the
cmb right although i do recall a paper
by turok maybe with others not with paul
though
where he contrived and you know you can
of course with enough
free parameters as von neumann said you
can make an elephant
you know and as uh add one more you make
his trunk wiggle i think um but yeah
you're right there that was kind of
ruled out you talk about that in the
book and it's a wonderful uh passage in
there what other like new or alternative
um data could one hope for to validate
the infinity of other worlds uh you know
what what else in addition i'm a cmb
maximalist uh you've heard of bitcoin
maximus i'm a cmb maximus so tell me
what what other tools do we have to you
know dial in uh and get more confidence
or refutation of the multiverse
well there are a couple of predictions
of inflation that we haven't tested yet
uh that are very specific uh and these
are called consistency relations
and these come about by connections
between different observable quantities
that are there because the perturbations
are generated by inflation
the the first one is a relationship
between
the
uh gravitational wave the the shape of
the spectrum of gravitational waves so
if you could not just measure primordial
gravity waves but measure them at
different wavelengths
the slope of that spectrum as a function
of wavelength is actually related to the
amplitude of the tensors the the gravity
waves in a particular way
right
and
you that that is in principle testable
it's difficult to do in practice but in
principle you can do it
and there's another one which is a
prediction for single field inflation
models which tells you that the
deviation from gaussian random
statistics should have a particular form
and this was first derived by juan
maldasena in 2002
and if we could get accurate enough
measurements of the
primordial perturbations on many many
scales that would also be a testable
thing
we probably won't do it with the cmb the
cmd alone is not powerful enough the
best bounds we're going to get on this
parameter for this non-gaussianity is of
order one right
uh even with something like the simon's
array or cmbs4 you're going to talk fnl
as an upper bound of around one where
from plot the upper bound is around four
so you're going to do it by you know
factor of four better with upcoming
experiments
but to really test the multisenior
relationship which tells you that that
should be about 10 to the minus two it's
about two orders of magnitude smaller
than what way the best we can do with
cmb
then you're going to have to talk about
measuring for example uh
neutral gas clouds during the dark ages
with 21 centimeter radiation for example
and that will uh if you could do that
you could actually test that so there's
a possibility in the
quite far future extremely difficult
measurements but in principle possible
where you could test other predictions
of this model that would really uh tend
to lend even more observational support
than we already have
um
and then uh one one thing that comes up
quite frequently
um you know throughout the book is is
this issue of non-gaussianity and i
wonder if you could describe for
listeners that are
technically savvy maybe or maybe not
what does non-gasianity refer to why is
that such a cornerstone of the
inflationary paradigm
well
the analogy i use in the book is imagine
you were in las vegas and you were
shooting craps
right and when you roll dice you roll
two dice
uh the most common possible roll you
have is a seven right and anything so
and then a a a six or an eight is less
common and a five or a nine is less
common and all the way out to like two
and twelves are really rare right so
there's a particular distribution of
probability according to what what
di you would roll and it's actually
approx it's it's a binomial distribution
it approximates what's what inflation
would predict is a gaussian distribution
so inflation predicts that certain
fluctuations in density will be more
probable than other fluctuations in
density and it forms what's called a
bell curve that's very very common in
nature the distribution of shoe size in
humans forms a belt curve uh you know
all kinds of probability distributions
form this what's called a gaussian or a
bell curve and inflation predicts that
the perturbation should have this
gaussian or bell curve shape
so
how do you test this right well testing
this is very much like going to vegas
and
trying to figure out whether or not the
dice you're rolling or loaded
right if the dice are loaded the
probability that you're going to get a
certain number is going to be shifted a
little bit and if they're a very clever
cheater they're going to make that shift
very small so it would be hard to notice
but so if you're trying to if you're
playing craps in vegas and you're trying
not to decide whether the dice are fair
or the dice are loaded one way you might
look for that is to say well
if i see a whole bunch more snake eyes
than i would expect from a normal
from a binomial distribution
i might i might start to guess that
those dice are loaded that the game is
fixed against me if i'm rolling lots and
way more 2s and 12s than i expect from a
from a standard probability distribution
so you could tell the dice are loaded by
playing for a long time plotting how
many numbers you get
as a function of
the role and you could see that if you
had extras if you had extra
rolls way out on those fringes you might
decide that the dice are loaded
same thing with non-gaussianity so
what's an example of an outlier uh uh in
these in the density perturbations it
would be really large density
perturbations huge shifts in the density
and what those would do for example is
those those very large fluctuations are
responsible for for example for seeding
clusters of galaxies the largest
structures in the universe
so one way you might look for loaded
dice for a non-gaussian distribution of
primordial perturbations
is if there are way more galaxy clusters
in the universe way more of these large
outliers than you would expect from a
standard probability distribution and
people have actually put bounds on
non-gaussianity from the abundance of
galaxy clusters using exactly that
method
so that's that's kind of that's the
process you would look it's like looking
for loaded dice in vegas
and then
why is that a consequence of inflation
uniquely
because inflation uh generates these
fluctuations in the universe by a
quantum mechanical process
and
in particular it's what's called a free
field is the technical term for it and
when you work through the math free
fields give you gaussian distributions
so it's a consequence of the fact that
inflation uses quantum mechanics to
generate the seed perturbations for
structure in the universe
so it's really kind of neat that you're
actually seeing this outcome of a
quantum mechanical process and you can
really test whether or not it's
consistent with that quantum mechanical
process by looking at the statistics of
the fluctuations it's a brilliant thing
and that's unique to inflation in other
words bouncing models scalar field
doesn't feature that or
or can it accommodate some bouncing
models have very strong non-gaussianity
right and a number of earlier proposals
for these bouncing models have been
ruled out by uh the fact that they would
have produced non-gaussianity much
larger than where we see bounds so that
there have actually been a number of
those bouncing models that have been
falsified on these grounds
so one of the powers of the theory i'm
an experimentalist what do i know but
one of the powers of a theory is the
ability to predict the you know
constituent parameters with some level
of of precision not just be accurate
and you know the question of you know
why
n sub s the the tilt of the scalar
spectral index why it has the particular
value it has it's certainly consistent
with inflation but is it is it a
consequence of the inflationary
obviously there's an infinite number of
points that could be consistent with it
um but um you know until we detect
tensor modes or if they if they are
detected conclusively this time uh not
not uh artificially uh so you know to
what extent is that you know the ability
to i mean should we have been able to
predict n sub s if inflation is right or
is it we need to know more about the
underlying theory before we could be
expected to make the prediction in other
words we calculated the lamb shift you
know 50 60 i didn't do it but somebody
did it back in the 50s and 60s uh 40s
and 50s rather and and you know that was
a consequence of our understanding of
qed and and i'm wondering you know is it
fair to require that that be a
prediction of uh in order to call
inflation rightly a proper you know
quantum field theory uh resultant of a
quantum filter
inflation does not make a definite
prediction for this which is the the
slope of the so if i plot the strength
of the the density perturbations in the
universe as a function of wavelength
that forms a power law and the slope of
that power law is called the spectral
index
um
and
this is something actually that is a
bone i have to pick with the
inflationary community at this point
because you see a lot people saying well
inflation predicts a slightly red
spectrum right which means that you
should have stronger perturbations on
long wavelength scales and and
less strong slightly less strong
perturbations on short wavelength scales
and that's in fact what we see right so
it's it's slightly red tilted that the
the perturbations at very long
wavelength are a little bigger than the
corresponding ones a very short
wavelength
that certainly is a consequence of some
inflationary models but it is not
generic and in fact before the red
spectrum was observed right which was
with the wmap satellite primarily came
up with the first real good bound on
that uh so the
the proof that the spectrum was in fact
uh non-scale invariant and uh a little
bit red
uh was came about mostly by the wmap
satellite and it was
quite well established by planck
in fact before that there was a
fairly widespread consensus in the
inflationary community was that the the
most attractive models of inflation from
supersymmetry and string theory
actually predicted the opposite
predicted a blue spectrum one that would
have greater bigger fluctuations on
short wavelengths
uh and these are called hybrid inflation
models and i went to many many many
talks where people said these are the
favorite models because this is what we
get out of supersymmetry and stranger
and
there has been very little institutional
memory of that now that we have seen a
red spectrum and uh it's become common
knowledge that inflation generically
predicts a red spectrum and this blue
spectrum was never really a good
prediction of inflation which is a
historical people said exactly the
opposite before the observation
so inflation doesn't make a good
prediction it can you can accommodate
any uh either a red or a blue spectrum
you can accommodate strongly tilted
spectra very weakly tilted spectra it's
a parameter of the theory it's not you
you can come up with a
reasonable inflationary model that will
accommodate all of these outcomes
is that a shortcoming of the theory well
it is what it is i mean it would be
really nice if inflation predicted
something specific for that but it does
not
right
very good well let's see will i want to
close with you know some of the
speculation that you talk about going
forward you're a professor
at uh top research university in my home
state of new york upstate we as we used
to call it uh not so far away where the
buffalo was genetically modified to make
wings i don't know how that happened but
we certainly love those uh treats down
over here and
we're about as far away from each other
as we could get and that's not by design
it's just worked out that way well
but i want to ask you if you're advising
a new student comes to your office
professor kinney got accepted to this
wonderful school
um what is the challenge that you posed
to him or her what what is the most
exciting thing if you were to start your
career again and go into this field with
you as your advisor
what would you advise such a student
what's the most exciting thing about
your field for inspiring a new student
to get involved in in the project of
what we call cosmology
i think i mean for me
this particular project of understanding
the early universe right uh if that's i
you know so let's just focus on that
because there are many other things that
i think are very exciting going on right
now exoplanets for example i'm i'm super
bullish on exoplanets as a field
um
bruno there you gotta be careful
well yeah
um
so but in terms of early universe
physics i think that one of the really
exciting things is that we are in a
we're in a process right now where we're
actually refining and able to refine and
test these models and this is a really
profound thing the idea that we can
actually test
models of particle physics at energy
scales that are
100 billion times as large as
the energies that we're testing at the
lhc
we're actually directly
accessing these with observational data
and coming up with real predictions that
we can test we can rule out models we
can do real physics this is not
philosophy this is hard-nosed
experimentally based empirical physics
that to me is a tremendously exciting
thing and i think that there's there's
still a big future in it in terms of
refining these models figuring out
predictions coming up with ways of
testing them and it's a difficult
process it's going to take a long time
and a lot of money and a lot of effort
but i think that
the the nature of the questions is so
profound that it's really worth it and i
and i remain excited by it
and you talk about just those stories at
the end and i think it's a delight to
consider these things no nowhere else in
science do you get to talk about the
origin of the entire universe aside from
cosmology so that's why and i always
tell my students you know aside from
biophysics if you study cosmology you
have access to every branch of physics
from quantum mechanics thermodynamics
observational uh technology
um solid state physics and everything on
the experimental side and analogous uh
depth on the theoretical side so i think
that's really fascinating
um so will now i want to speculate
outside the realm of uh of hardcore
science that you were a master of i want
to speak about
philosophy maybe even theology if you're
willing to go there
and um what about these stories these we
started off talking about bruno
obviously inter you know
related uh with uh with with theology
with the catholic church in that case um
in my case i've been practicing jew uh
the torah the five books of moses the
old testament starts with the creation
of the universe in some sense um to what
extent do
is our
questions of
our existence of ultimate meaning of the
philosophy or theology
uh uh that's underpins reality is that
of interest to you not is it important
to your daily job it's obviously not but
what to what level does it motivate you
or or maybe not and you may be an
atheist i don't know uh but are there
aspects outside of physics metaphysics
even that you find worthy of of of
devoting some of your uh attention to
well i mean i'm a pretty hardcore
atheist uh so i you know i i am not a
religious person per se
um
but i think that when you start to talk
about these
edge cases like for example the the
inflationary multiverse which is in
principle untestable right this these
other universes are things that you will
because of just inescapable rules of
causality you'll never be able to to see
so at that point it's so you're starting
to blur the boundaries between
what i call a hard no scientific idea
something that is empirically verifiable
you can test these inflation models and
so on but then when you say you take
these well-tested models and you just
say what's the consequence of this
you end up with a universe that looks
absolutely nothing like what you started
the basic the fundamental structure of
the universe is completely different
not only that it's something that you
have no way of testing
and at that point you sort of slipped
beyond the boundary of what you can
really even call science and you're
you're really addressing more
philosophical questions
and
i don't have any answers and and one of
the things i try to do in the book is
really be be honest and clear about the
point at which not only do we not
understand things but it may be that it
won't be possible for us in any
reasonable sense to understand
the you know to answer some of these
questions and that puts us in a very
difficult place as scientists and i
don't know how to resolve that cognitive
dissonance i have no advice for anybody
except that it seems to be true we walk
we we take these theories that we can
test we calculate their consequences and
it gives us this completely crazy
picture of the world that we have
ultimately no way of being able to go
out and verify
and where that leaves us philosophically
or religiously i i honestly don't know
and and i i
i have no particular answer which is
okay i guess you know it's maybe maybe
there are some questions that uh that
the science is
sort of fundamentally forbidden from
answering and one of the interesting
things is that you can use this science
this process of
scientific deduction to demarcate those
boundaries in a in a well-defined
mathematical way which i find
fascinating actually that we can
actually measure where that boundary
between where the where science starts
to break down and where we can no longer
say anything with confidence we can
we can find that boundary very very
accurately now using science
as uh
stephen j gould used to call it the
non-overlapping magisteria and uh
we uh we have
i think a lot to learn from folks that
can be comfortable in each camp without
being you know attacking or being too
strident in their views and i think it
is uh it's delightful to think about
these things and i always say you know
to my students
you know if you don't think about these
things sometimes like
you may not be in the right field for
really there's so many because in very
few other fields of physics you know you
study solid state you know nemectic
super conduct you're not going to think
about necessarily this is the work of
god or that that the multiverse spawn an
infinite number of you know that would
allow without much fine-tuning according
to like fred adams and other people uh
that you could have you know such a such
a behavior no you won't typically most
people won't think about that as part of
their job but we effectively get paid to
think about such questions and i think i
think it's delightful and we should take
advantage of it even if we don't agree
yeah i think that uh maybe maybe to
finish up i can talk about so they're
they're basically inflation brings two
thing two philosophical problems to the
fore one is that the if you like accept
inflation as the picture of the universe
or even some of these cyclic models as
we as we are now discovering you have to
come to terms with the idea that the
universe had a beginning that there was
some sort of initial state even if it
wasn't a singularity it was something
where other physics must have been
taking place and the second one is in
inflation you have this infinite
multiverse you're you're constantly
producing new universes uh infinitely
into the future
and one thing that bruno did in the
1500s was realize that these two
problems were linked
and he grappled with both of these
problems in a in a way that is very
was very prescient and very uh really
anticipated modern sensibilities in that
he realized that the
infinity of worlds in some sense could
give one a framework which would allow
you to understand the idea that the
universe had a beginning as well
uh that it sort of it sort of softens
the philosophical impact in a way
because it the that beginning is is
diluted infinitely by the by the
infinity of worlds and and it becomes
you know it becomes less of a
philosophical conundrum you don't have
to care so much about aristotle's prime
mover anymore because the prime mover is
infinitely removed from anything that
you would actually have any practical
concern for so i think bruno in in his
copernican view of the universe paints a
philosophical picture that allows us to
understand an inflationary multiverse in
a very simple way uh and
i i find that very satisfying yes
of course you know we don't have to we
don't have access to what uh to what
referee number two said about bruno uh
it probably wasn't that good number two
set him on fire that's right
they were a lot harsher back then damn
yeah we complain about referee number
two today but we don't know how good we
got it um well it's been a delight to
talk to you and i wonder if now you'd be
willing to go into the impossible and
answer my thrilling three
existential questions about uh your life
and thoughts philosophy
and uh your testimony for the future if
you'd be willing to play the game i call
the thrilling three three three
[Music]
first question uh relates to your
relatively you know hopefully not too
near term but your ultimate future uh
when you go into the springing forth of
the mortal coil as the bard called it uh
going into the future and your so-called
ethical will which has to do not with
will kinney but with your bequeathment
to future generations biological
ideological i want to ask you if you
were to put something some piece of
wisdom or some teaching
of an ethical or wisdom-based process
not material into your material will
what would you put into your ethical
will
i think i mean
one of the
[Music]
things that i think is an underlying
theme
that i try to keep in mind as a teacher
right i teach science to students and i
so i have lots of everywhere from uh
beginning students in a jet and gen ed
class so i teach a general education
astronomy class with theater majors and
business majors in it all the way up to
graduate classes
i think the thing that is a theme that
connects all of those and that i i as a
teacher i try to pass down to a younger
generation is the value of a scientific
worldview
of really
valuing evidence and
and rational thinking as a as a as a way
to organize your viewpoint on the world
i think it's extraordinarily powerful
and i think it's something that that
every human being can benefit from and
as a science teacher
i am the point of contact for a lot of
students in developing that scientific
worldview as a citizen and as a and as a
as a human being and and for me it's
been a very powerful
uh
philosophical organizing principle and
it's something i try to pass on to
others as well
wonderful and now we're going to go a
little bit further into the future and
ask you to look into your crystal ball
and that crystal ball uh will reveal to
my audience what you think is the most
highest accomplishment of humanity and i
i phrased this in terms of the movie
2001 a space odyssey there are these
monoliths that proliferate throughout
the galaxy and the earth and you see in
the very beginning these primitive
primates hitting it with a bone and
trying to break it open we don't really
know what it is it could be a could be
an omen it could be a a usb drive
who knows what it is but it could be a
time capsule so i like to think of it as
a time capsule so if i ask you will if
you had a time capsule that you knew for
sure would last a billion years looking
into the crystal ball in the future what
would you put on it or in it to
summarize to kind of brag and show a
little swagger for what humanity has
accomplished in your field or in
anything really
so if i had something that i could send
to the
the alien civilization that discovers
the remnants of ours correct i think um
what i would what i would put in uh
preferentially over anything else
is our art and literature
i think that that's
by far the thing that defines us most as
human beings i mean presumably whatever
alien creatures would come and discover
this would have science similar to ours
and they would in fact have probably
have a far profounder understanding of
the world than we do now
but what makes us human and what makes
us unique creatures in the world is our
uh
is our
is our really our humanity as expressed
in our in our arts and in our culture uh
and and these are the things that i
think
of the species that i would be most
anxious to preserve
that's very reminiscent of past guests
on the show and fellow upstate new york
denizen andrewian
widow of carl sagan finger lakes denizen
who said that she would put her brain
waves on a golden disc and attach it to
the pioneer spacecraft and then she kind
of brag said well i actually did that
she is the one person who has actually
done this
yeah she claims it'll last four billion
years so i'm shortchanging one billion
she said nasa told her it's gonna last
forward okay last question will now
we're going backwards in time
for some advice to your former self and
this uh is actually the raison d'etre of
this podcast in a certain sense and it
harkens to another one of arthur c
clarke's famous laws he had many laws of
course you're probably familiar with the
one that goes like this any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic that's how we open the show
and uh the second law is uh is for every
expert there's an equal and opposite
expert which i like to lay on my
department chair from time to time uh
and then the third law states the
following the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
beyond them into the impossible that's
how i get the name of the podcast i want
to ask you in kind of turning that
around
advice to your former self 20 year old
will
what would you tell him to give him the
courage to do as you have done to go
into the impossible
[Music]
well there's another quote from clark
that i think applies here too which is
that uh if an elderly scientist if an
elderly and distinguished scientist
says that something is possible he is
almost uncertain or certainly correct
and if he says it is impossible he is
almost certainly incorrect
uh
and
i i think that
so my advice going back to my 20 year
old self or to whatever whatever human
being is is a current version of that
is
to
keep a radically open mind
and to not limit yourself in terms of
saying that you know
this is this sort of narrow version of
reality that we that we're stuck in and
because that will only
if if you if you keep your viewpoint too
narrow and you and you don't and you
don't ever venture outside that then
you'll only ever do things that are
derivative i think that the people who
have come up with the great ideas have
been the ones who have dared to
uh believe in things that were or
considered things that were believed in
conventional wisdom to be impossible
uh and and so i i think that that that
clark quote capsule encapsulates that
pretty well to to to working within the
theme yes the theme of impossibility and
to old scientists
well hold on i'm an old scientist now
and you know i i think maybe i'm a
little too set in my ways and uh i hope
that there's some young person out there
who just like blows it all away and
comes up with something even better yeah
that's the hope will hold up the book
please
hold up the book
will kenny author of infinite not that
side the side with my name on it i don't
care about it
there we go that's the money shot brian
keating there we go
well i want to thank you uh it's been a
delight to chat with you uh i love
following you on twitter and you could
be found there and we'll have links to
the book obviously
and to your twitter account and anything
else you'd like to mention right now
will before we uh
the book is uh will be it's available
for pre-order uh uh uh prior to
publication it will it appears in
bookstores on uh april 5th tuesday uh we
were recording this a little bit before
that so um it'll be out by the time yeah
the book will be out by the time
we'll have links to it uh to buy it
directly contribute to will's retirement
fund uh well it's a delightful book it
was a fast easy delightful delicious and
comment on and really an update guth's
classic book from 1995 or six or seven
or whatever that was
told by one of the real uh heavy lifters
in the field you do a lot will for
communication for outreach for education
uh you do it selflessly and uh it's a
delight to uh to speak to you finally
after uh after so long i i don't think i
don't we must have met at one point but
i hope to see you in person maybe i can
come there in january and you can come
here in january and we'll get a taste of
uh how each other lives we can swap yeah
we'll do a house swap thank you brian
thank you have a great day bye bye
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
if you like this video check here for a
playlist that i created just for you
[Music]
[Music]
you